- C'est ce message bouleversant
que le Dr Sébastien Marin,
chef d'urgence à l'Hôpital
Barrie Memorial, a publié tôt ce
matin sur Twitter, afin que
cette mort ne soit pas vaine.
"J'ai terminé ma nuit sur un
patient qui est décédé devant
moi avec une aorte thoracique
qui a rompu, écrit-il. Moi,
je n'ai rien pu faire."
La veille, ce même patie
raconte-t-il, aurait attendu
durant 16 heures dans un autre
hôpital. Incapable de voir un
médecin, il aurait dé é é de
rebrousser chemin."
Dr SÉBASTIEN MARIN, médecin
urgenti. Hôpital Barrie Miaiaial
- Je vois des patients qui
décèdent à tous les jours,
c'est la vie, mais, lui,
il ne devait pas décéder.
- Le patient, âgé dususus de
70 ans, était pourtant connu
pour son anévrisme.
- C'est un patient qui n'aurait
pas dû attendre à l'urgence.
C'est un cas qui était quand
même assez clair, c'est un cas
qui est très dangeureux.
Dr GILBERT BOUCHER, prés., Asso.
spécialistes méd. d'urgence, QC
- Si ce patient-là avait pu être
vu dans des temps raisonnables,
on ne dit pas qu'il aurait
survécu, mais au m i i il aurait
eu une chance.
- Le Dr Gilbert Boucher craint
que d'autres patients puissent
écoper en raison de l'état du
système de santé québécois.
- L'engorgement est terrible,
on est en bris de service,
on ne peut plus servir la
population, il y a des risques
pour la population.
- Partout dans la province,
les urgences débordent,riririen.
- On espère toujours que
le système de triage va faire
en sorte qu'on ne passera pas à
travers des... on ne manquera
pas d es phatologies comme ça.
Malheureusmenet, encore une
fois, depuis cinq ou six mois,
il y a beaucoup de patients qui
repartent sans voir de médecin.
- Mis au fait de cette affaire,
le cabinet du ministre de la
Santé, Christian Dubé, dit
avoir demandé sur-le-champ
un état de situation détaillé
des évènements à l'établissement
de santé.
"Avec les changements qu'on est
en train de faire, on va rendre
le réseau beaucoup plus solide
et performant dans les années à
venir", assure son cabinet.
- Est-ce que je crois aux
réformes? Bien, ça...
Oui, mais ça va être long.CCÇa t
des années.
- Le Dr Gilbert Boucher croit
que des actions sont nécessaires
dès maintenant pour désengorger
les urgences.
- Il faut trouver un moyen de
sortir les patients qui n'ont
plus besoin d'urgence de
l'urgence.
- Sans quoi, une autre mort,
évitable, pourrait survenir à
tout moment.
Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-Canada, Montreal.